US News and World Report says
surveillance video taken inside a Penn
State fraternity house before student
died is expected to be shown in court
today
19 year-old Timothy Piazza died after
several fall down the stairs at the Beta
Theta Pi building he reportedly drank a
large amount of alcohol during a hazing
ritual that night the fraternity along
with 18 of its members face criminal
charges
DeMarco Morgan is outside the
Pennsylvania courthouse where
prosecutors are expected to show the
surveillance footage
DeMarco good morning good morning
today's preliminary hearing will
determine whether the 18 Beta Theta Pi
brothers and their fraternity should
stand trial these surveillance videos is
of course a huge part of the
prosecution's case because it allegedly
shows the final hours of Tim Piazza's
the video tape is horrible and it is
gruesome
Tim Piazza's family attorney says they
haven't decided whether they'll be in
the courtroom when the surveillance
videos have played no parent wants to
see what apparently is on this videotape
the videos were recorded by security
cameras inside the Beta Theta Pi house
on February 2nd and have never been seen
publicly according to the grand jury
presentment around 9:00 p.m. the video
show Piazza and other pledges in a
ritual called the gauntlet consuming
large amounts of beer vodka and wine in
a matter of minutes
shortly after Piazza apparently fell
headfirst down the basement stairs when
he reappears on camera carried by
fraternity brothers his body is limp and
his abdomen clearly bruised these
videotapes will undoubtedly show the
various acts which are spelled out in
the grand jury report the dragging of a
young man failing to attend to him
punching him and other acts which appear
in the grand jury report to be
indefensible around 5:00 a.m. the
cameras captured Piazza falling
headfirst into an iron railing shortly
after 7:00 a.m. he apparently fell down
the basement stairs again
the fraternity brothers didn't find him
for another three hours and then waited
42 minutes to call 911
is unconscious she never moves he also
died one day later a pathologist said he
had severe head trauma and a ruptured
spleen attorney Rocco sipper own jr.
represents Michael Bonaduce who faces
eight charges in Piazza's death I know
the Bobby Tucci family and Michael in
particular certainly feel empathy and
sympathy for the Piazza families but
sadly just because someone passes away
doesn't mean that everybody in the room
is responsible a prosecutors filed a
variety of charges against the
defendants including involuntary
manslaughter hazing and tampering with
evidence
the fraternity told us last month they
do not tolerate hazing or alcohol abuse
but added the defendants are entitled to
the presumption of innocence nor tough
to hear those details and Marco thank
you there hear that he was abused like
that allegedly averag it's on tape Nora
and was in pain for so long yeah
heartbreaking